hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to time or now if you
remember NOx time or it was a game that
I played a while ago that a lot of
really good scares and also it spawned
an animation made by cranbersher it's
really cool one if it's if I remember
there will be one right over there
there'd be a link to the video where you
can watch the animation made about NOx
I'm armed but this is time or and I
believe this one was made before NOx
timore so they lie apparently I'm just
lying to you I have no idea you but
you're not dead yet time or we'll fix
that I still don't know if I'm
pronouncing time war incorrectly but
because I play games always out of order
this is just the natural result of
things oh it's an endless hallway is it
oh it's dark and mysterious is it oh hey
I see you over there don't think that
you can out sass me I see you over there
hey you want to fight bro are you time
or are you ready for this back down not
the Smackdown the Smackdown it's much
worse it's about ten times worth alright
okay you're a little creepier now I'm
getting closer can I help you god damn
it don't try to do that with me who's in
there mr. squeaky door anybody oh wait
what what wait wait wait a minute
hang on I see some mist over there oh
it's a chair for mind didn't want a
chair see the thing about Knox time or
is that it looked I don't know oh I do
have a flashlight
think about Knox time or is that when I
played it it looks stupid it looked
poorly made and just utter crap and I
mean this one doesn't look good by any
stretch of the imagination but oddly
enough hit like scared the crap out of
me when I play Knox time or slide some
of the puzzles which okay so where am I
supposed to go here because a lot of a
lot of Knox
oh hey this is tonight can I drop down
this giant hole no all right
can I go to the bloody toilet apparently
not all right so what am i doing over
here yeah see the thing about time or or
Knox time or was that there was a lot of
going back and forth and a lot of things
that didn't exactly make sense Oh
that being said ah physics I sure you
stupid chair get out of here is there a
point to all this is there a reason why
I played Knox time or not time or so
your stupid game okay
alrighty then okay so that was the thing
I'm glad that happened at least
something happened alright never mind
then think about this game as it's
deceptive counter Wumpus to what I think
is gonna happen
hello I wasn't supposed to find like a
key somewhere was I cuz if I was then I
missed it and I'm stupid don't agree
with that wait a minute whoa whoa wait a
minute that's different I thought were
okay what
but that bouquet hi how's it going hey
friends been a while since I saw you
alright cool we're all having fun here
oh so that's how you're gonna play this
game a game huh
see that's what it is about this I have
to go back and forth between places it's
deceptive hi Fran he's gone was your
head poking through
no come on okay I made myself look
stupid but you're not gonna question
that at all
hello I'm back again baby I'm home
come out and scare me oh boy yeah
nothing wonder if there's something back
ooh what is that the labyrinth oh boy
it's exactly what I wanted
great what what's that hello hi my name
is markiplier I'm currently unarmed and
innocent and totally vulnerable please
don't kill me
okay okay okay I almost saw that right
away there's blood everywhere it's in my
blood so long as it's not my blood I'm
not particularly worried I'm putting my
faith in myself not myself okay
did you make all this blood was this
your ado okay okay never mind what was
that
why does it keep doing that why does it
keep doing hi oh it's good to see you
something maybe you could go down I'd be
great too hi dawn do doubt me don't do
nothing to me cuz I got a key I'm gonna
see what it do look at the toilet so the
toilet please yes I have to poop it's
cute you sorry did I interrupt something
is someone over here why are these
bathroom doors wooden
oh thank you please god dammit okay so
that was a little forgiving I thought it
was gonna do sh me over and I was I have
to go back to the damn beginning oh good
good good good at least it's not like
that i I wasn't me doctor kitchen key I
don't know where the kitchen be but I
got the carry off [ __ ] you I don't know
why that's told me more than anything
else I guess I should just expect those
guys gonna be no I said shut up I
remember distinctly saying you two shut
up hello friend
[Music]
one of their shelving units I don't like
these guys and the the explicit reason
is because I have a fear of mannequins
there there they're mannequins pretty
much pure and simple the flip-flapping
mannequins hi well alright then that was
cool
oh god more knocking am I gonna die this
game it's it's it's it's not like it
leads you to false sense of security
that's what it do goddamn it
oh no that's just a normal flashing
light there's got to be another door
around here somewhere maybe in the
labyrinth entrance Oh kitchen yeah
okay stop doing that
oh good it's another one of those things
it's gonna change everything on me
something's gonna happen something's
gonna happen I hope I got the Roberti
okay all right
that wasn't as bad as I thought it was
gonna be all right so this is lovely and
all but why is there a kitchen in a
hellhole of no life and sadness don't
tell me it's a school because obviously
hello okay I think I got it is that a
watermelon or a face I'm not sure but
it's bloody so it's a bleeding laughs
[ __ ] you god damn it
oh you suck oh god you suck that one
really got me oh damn it
all right cool great I'm just gonna be
on my way
my heart's pounding out of my chest but
that's okay god damn it I knew there was
a point to those holes in the ground the
son of a [ __ ] game with all its jump
scares see John scares by themselves are
often pretty crappy hi googly hands but
I don't know what it is about these ones
cuz I don't even have my volume turned
up all that loud it's just it's very
surprising it just all stems from the
fact that I don't expect a lot out of it
and then all son boo boo boo boo boo I'm
jumping out of my skin top that I don't
know what that is so stop it so I got
the locker room key and after that I
think I just need to go down the
labyrinth and I should be a-okay to go
on bout my day stop it I don't want to
answer the door I don't want to it's not
a good place for me to be endued that
good great Wow why is there a locker
room
do you have a team of something
I'm not opening all these oh god I'm not
opening all these oh hi is that one that
is open yeah no no no way no no way
there's no way that I would open all of
these oh good it's a thing on the ground
shut up no no good Leopard
hi I knew you were gonna be behind me I
knew it I don't have the patience to
open all of them I definitely don't have
the OCD to do so I hear it knocking I
opened the ones that he knocked from but
it was a bunch of lies
those damn things are so simplistic but
still they bug me oh boy the long walk
back I wonder what's gonna happen now Oh
Damon's gonna pop out and go boo boo you
all wondered oh come on no no no hello
dead body are you made of watermelons
can I go back now that fix everything
oh good okay it's all good all right
if I hadn't have done that oh man if I
had turned around I would have been
walking all the way to the end and it
would have been really pissed off oh
that's what I think of all you and your
IKEA shopping
okay hello they were just waving to me
all right you're on the different side
now I didn't notice you there before so
the big question is why in the world
would I want to go through the labyrinth
because frankly I've seen Pan's
Labyrinth and I played God of War so
technically they're not all good okay
here we go
completely voluntarily into the
labyrinth where things shake and shimmy
what I can't move
okay cool damn you I said what I
shouldn't know those holes in the ground
mean bad things happening oh come on I
can smell freedom from over there
mmm
god damn it what huh what happened what
what what I died oh come on don't tell
me that's how it's gonna be I think it's
my way say by me hi what are you - Elias
that you are huh wheezing okay never
mind I've changed my mind
okay it really was by me oh he's so
scary
hey Jo adorably scary okay Wow oh that's
ominous and long and hard and weird you
were just fakies what I can't move
oh really well really really really oh
hi how's it going okay alrighty then
apparently I'm still alive maybe I found
the right way to go okay
maybe this is gonna put on a good show
stop it with the hole in the ground
you've done that already
oh good back to the music again am I
still in the labyrinth please tell me
I'm almost done please
was that you telling me I'm almost done
yeah thank you Oh am I done
is this the hallway of accomplishment is
this like the end of star wars are you
gonna do it again you son of a [ __ ] I
knew you were gonna you miss me with
your tentacles ya weirdo slender woman
right yay did I won dude i won hi okay
that's a thing so what's gonna happen
out of that thing there's something at
the end of the hallway concerned okay it
was oh hey I'm a little weirded out but
okay so apparently that was the wrong
door oh god damn it what the hell where
am I okay so this time if I see someone
running it towards me I'm going to turn
around and go the other way
what's the killer stop it with that I
just spit all over my monitor again
because of you okay actually gonna go
away this time okay running as fast as I
can
cuz they're probably right behind me
they not right behind me or what was it
a bug that they were supposed to go away
Oh God walls a fire they better not be
closing in on me or something I get it
you're trying to jump out and startled
me and you got a lot of pyrotechnics you
got a big budget I get it
what the hell is this does the exit door
yes god they look so pretty
I guess maybe there's more hang on maybe
I was done too soon I was of the
understanding that this wasn't a real
place oh okay there was more well I'm
just trapped forever thanks for playing
okay I was under the assumption that was
the end there oh okay that makes a lot
more sense okay so anyway no one can say
that this game was great
obviously level design sucks repetitive
the character models the art was not
that great sound wasn't all their music
wasn't all there but all that aside why
like Knox time or was the fact that this
game was interesting it was interesting
it got me there's bad horror games that
I played that I just laughed at the jump
scares but this one I mean in the
beginning more than at the end at the
end it got a little old but in the
beginning like it still got me and I
don't have my volume like cranked up to
maximum it just got me so I really hope
you guys enjoyed that because I know
that's like the essence of what watching
me play scary games is it goes burr and
I go and then you guys laugh at my
misery
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for enduring this
video if it was a bit tedious for you
but hopefully it was cut down into
something enjoyable and a lot of me
screaming so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Applause]